ja ich habe es eben erwähnt 4,6
Millionen abgelaufene Impfdosen lagern
bei -25 Grad das gab das
Gesundheitsministerium auf Anfrage von
FDP Vize Wolfgang Kubicki bekannt eine
Begründung aus dem Hause Lauterbach
warum diese Massen an Impfstoff nicht
schon längst entsorgt werden ja man
könne eventuell eine Verlängerung der
Haltbarkeit erreichen ein Thema über das
wir hier heute sprechen wollen frei
haben wir noch sie sind Energieexpertin
ist das nicht eine Milchmädchenrechnung
naja also man könnte natürlich noch
diese Dosen jetzt einfach weg tun wenn
sie verbraucht sind nicht mehr gebraucht
werden können ich bin der Meinung dass
man sowieso viel zu viel gekauft hat und
ich bin auf der Meinung dass man
insgesamt bei Corona drastisch
übertrieben hat wir haben ja nicht nur
diese Frage des bisschen Energie um die
kühl zu halten wenn man ganz viele
andere Sachen auch verbockt in den zwei
Jahren und die Unternehmer müssen das
ausbaden also ich denke das Corona
vorbei ist ich glaube auch nicht dass
das in dem Maße wiederkommen wir
brauchen auch keine Impfdosen mehr dafür
sieht der Gesundheitsminister wie wir
gerade gesehen haben ganz anders haben
sie noch irgendwas im Keller was sie
sagen vielleicht abgekühlt was Sie nicht
mehr brauchen aber ich finde das ist
schon ein richtiger Punkt also das ist
ich glaube auch also ich weiß nicht wie
viel Energie man braucht um diese Dosen
jetzt zu kühlen aber das ist tatsächlich
ein ein Symbol dafür dass man dass man
also ständig auf Overkill gesetzt hat
dass man und wir können ganz bestimmt
jetzt nicht so weitermachen also es hat
ja so viele Zweifel an der Impfung
tatsächlich auch gegeben an den
Nebenwirkungen das wird jetzt alles
langsam diskutiert ich war immer sehr
fürs m-impfen insofern müssen wir
fairerweise sagen wir haben natürlich
lauter aber auch gedrängt also wir haben
oder dann damals sparen gedrängt also
wir wollen wir brauchen jetzt endlich
Impfstoff warum kommt der nichts tun
vielleicht also ein bisschen überzogen
ist auch Nummer sicher gegangen aber
jetzt was soll's das heißt wenn er was
glauben kannst du dieser Fehlplanung
kommen
Pandemie machen ja das Skandal ist ja
nicht dass 4,6 Millionen zu viel gekauft
worden sind das Skandal ist mit die ist
jeder Tag die diese 4,6 Millionen
offiziell abgelaufen gekühlt werden und
liegen und er das riecht weil wir diese
dieser Ausrede wir suchen jetzt eine
Möglichkeit dass irgendwie zu verlängern
also wenn wenn Edeka das jetzt sagen
würde für die abgelaufenen Lebensmittel
dann gibt es sonst was ja den Joghurt
dann noch kaufen
aber wo ist der Politiker der jetzt
einfach sagt okay Leute wir haben vor
ein zwei Jahren Fehler gemacht ja das
wird doch jeder verstehen weil keiner
das besser machen kann aber jetzt muss
eine Entscheidung ja dann wenn da 4,6
Millionen ranzige Schweinehälften hängen
ja und gekühlt werden dann kommen
nächsten Tage die
tierkörperverwertungsanstalt da muss
eine Entscheidung her ja und nicht so
eine faule Ausrede ja wir haben noch
eine wir suchen noch einen Weg die
Schweinehälfte die das Ganze zu
entfernen Entscheidung aber auch eine
Entschuldigung Entschuldigung ja über
werden Bekenntnisse Entschuldigung
gefordert ich bin kein Freund von ich
bin Freund von Maßnahmen und von
Wahrheit man muss zugeben wenn Fehler
gemacht worden sind wenn wenn bestimmte
Lage bestimmte also bestimmte Maßnahmen
müssen die definiert und getroffen
werden und durchgezogen werden so
gewinnt man auch das Vertrauen der
Bürger wieder also das Vertrauen ist
doch etwas tiefer verletzt glaube ich
bei vielen Leuten wenigstens im Drittel
der Bevölkerung nach meinem Dafürhalten
und dann müsste man also ein einfacher
wie tut mir leid habe ich mich geirrt
wird nicht reichen entschuldigung das
geht nicht aber zu sagen wir haben da
auch überzogen wir haben da auch nicht
auf die anderen gehört wir haben den
Disput nicht zugelassen damit nicht
zugelassen und das halte ich für ganz
wichtig wir werden jetzt immer mehr
Leute mit Impfschäden haben die Debatte
wird also sowieso kommen und die Frage
ist wie lange die Politik die vor sich
herschieben will natürlich hat man am
Anfang erstmal alles gemacht das finde
ich auch richtig wenn ich weiß und mir
das zu tun hast gehst erstmal auf Nummer
sicher und wartest ne und die älteren
Leute im Lande haben sich auch ein
bisschen beschützt gefühlt das muss auch
sagen aber jetzt gucken Sie doch mal
wenn es jetzt gerade alles trifft mit
den impfen und wer das ist welche Alter
und die Kinder haben sich weniger
beschützen also unsere Ministerpräsident
Sachsen hat gesagt wir hätten die Kitas
und Schulen nicht schließen müssen das
war ein Fehler die haben sich langsam so
ein bisschen in Richtung tut uns leid
aber es gibt keine klare Auswertungen
was viele Leute gelebt haben war dass
sie drangsaliert worden sind die wurden
von ihren Jobs entfernt den wurde
angekündigt dass sie vielleicht
eingesperrt werden sie haben bestimmte
Bereiche im Leben nicht betreten dürfen
es ist war richtig hart
hier klar gibt es diese diese Frage
inwieweit die Politik Masken Impfung und
so weiter berechtigt war nicht
berechtigt war ja die gibt es sowieso
aber hier haben wir ja mal ein konkretes
Problem okay 4,6 Millionen Abgeordneten
da kann die Politik mal zeigen sie kann
was tun und sie kann was bewegen und
damit würde auch schon ein Stückchen ich
gebe zu die ganze wird das Ganze
Vertrauen in die Politik würde damit
nicht wiedergekommen werden aber ein
Stückchen wäre es und passiert nichts
eines Mannes oder Karl Lauterbach ich
glaube wir alle wissen ganz normal ist
er nicht das denke ich kann man so sagen
es gibt Leute denken er hat eine Macke
ob das stimmt weiß ich nicht aber es ist
für mich wie ein griechischer tragischer
Held der nicht eingestehen kann dass er
hier falsch lag und jetzt druckt er
darum sagt er hofft auf irgendeine
Verlängerung dass die vielleicht doch
noch haltbar sind und deswegen will er
sie nicht aus der Kühlkammer rausholen
ja und ist einfach so jemand der so
festgefahren in seinen Meinungen ist
dass er da nicht raus kann es gibt
einige Sachen sozusagen einer Sackgasse
er hat einen Trip gemacht nach Israel
dieses Jahr wir haben bei Bild groß
darüber berichtet da hat er in dem
Flieger dahin nach Tel Aviv Schokolade
gefunden und dann gesagt einer von
unseren Reporterin war dabei und dann
hat er gesagt wer hat hier Schokolade
mitgebracht das ist so ungesund hatte
die alle eingesagt wieso irre ja als
Minister und diese Anekdote hat finde
ich gezeigt schnell noch aufgegessen ich
hätte glaube man und es hat der der ist
so wie sie sagen genau aber ich finde
Lauterbach ist ein Thema tatsächlich
aber es waren schon mehr Leute die Brust
tun der Überzeugung und da gehört die
ehemalige Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel
und definitiv auch dazu und ihr
Kanzleramtsminister und alle haben
geredet im im Brust tun der Überzeugung
mit großem Phase und jetzt wird halt
wieder vermieden also hier ist es
vergleichsweise Detailprobleme mit den
Impfdosen aber auch Lauterbach vermeidet
jetzt wieder sorgfältig irgendwie
zuzugeben dass irgendwas nicht richtig
und nicht gut war mir geht's gar nicht
so sehr um die Entschuldigung sondern
mir geht es darum die haben in einer
sehr unsicheren Situation das gestehen
wir Ihnen alle zu das man konnte es
nicht genau wissen getan als ob sie ganz
genau wissen was sie tun und das mit mit
großer Betonung und und auch moralischer
Keule durchgezogen jeder der eine
abweichende Meinung hatte wollte
eigentlich alte Leute umbringen
heute noch verimpfen werden haben sie
ihre Einstellung zum Impfen auch im Zuge
der Pandemie ich würde eine Sache vorher
also ich will gar keine Entschuldigung
dafür kann man sich gar nicht
entschuldigen man kann Verzeihung finden
aber auch das muss nicht sein aber ein
Wort das dauert
geworden deswegen frage ich Sie das ob
sie auch in das ist ja dann auch der
Punkt ob sie auch das Überdenken dass
anders
breiter ist und dass man offensichtlich
dass im Schäden irgendwie vorkommen und
dass man doch darüber reden muss und es
ist ja auch es ist ja auch naheliegend
also es war ein vollkommen neues
Medikament das ganz schnell
in die Praxis gedrückt wurde und es ist
es wäre fast lebensfremd zu sagen dass
da nicht später noch noch zusätzliche
Erkenntnisse auftauchen und sie ist dann
im Rückblick dafür geworden zu haben ich
habe
also ich glaube immer noch ja ich weiß
gar nicht ich war nie für die
Impfpflicht ich glaube ich war
zwischendurch mal aber ganz kurz hat
diese abwegigen Standpunkt also im Sinne
von ja wenn man das nicht machen lässt
dann kann man weiß ich nicht dann dann
dann kein Krankengeld oder irgend so ein
Scheiß habe ich mal geschrieben aber das
war glaube ich wirklich nur einmal ja
aber okay
ja also es ist ja also es ist ja viel
Schaden angerichtet worden also und zwar
also wie bei der Impfung wissen wir das
Ende der Geschichte noch gar nicht ich
glaube schon dass sie gewirkt hat im
Sinne von weniger Todesfälle das haben
wir schon gesehen also nach der zweiten
Welle mit tausend Toten am Tag das
hatten wir schon alle das Gefühl oh wow
und das ist jetzt ein bisschen viel und
das ist danach ja dramatisch also als
dann durchgeimpft wurde zurückgegangen
man kriegt ja offensichtlich trotzdem
drei bis viermal so also habe ich kenne
Leute die hatten die sind Folge geimpft
unter uns viermal jetzt schon gehabt
also das ist noch eine offene Geschichte
aber andere Sachen wissen wir jetzt wir
wissen dass die Kita und Schuld also bei
den Kita schließen sogar durch eine
Studie bei den Schulschließung kann man
das analog relativ wahrscheinlich
vermuten dass die völlig unbegründet
waren weil Ansteckung dort unterhalb der
Ansteckung in den Familien lag aber wir
wissen jetzt auch was die Schäden bei
den Kindern und Jugendlichen angerichtet
haben
das war schlimm und das war auch falsch
das machen auch nicht wieder und das
würden wir genauso auch nicht wieder
machen und und darauf warte ich also die
ganze Zeit und genau von der Lauterbach
ist zu erwarten ist wahrscheinlich das
hoffnungslos aber Frau Merkel wir
erinnern uns alle an die osterruhe
erinnern entschuldigt hat sich
entschuldigt und deswegen muss man ein
bisschen skalieren in diesem blaming
jetzt hinterher oh keiner hat sich bei
uns entschuldigt es gibt so Leute
diese Entscheidung revidiert und sich
für die Entscheidung entschuldigt und
auch gehandelt das muss
ich dann einmal dahin zu stellen vor dem
Bundestag und zu sagen sorry es war mein
Fehler das hat sie so gesagt so mein
Fehler alleine war schon groß
in der Situation
ich glaube wenn diese Erfahrung ein
gutes hat ja und dann sollte es unter da
sind also alle die sogenannten
Öffentlichkeit beteiligt sind ja auch
aufgerufen
wir sollten endlich einmal so diese zu
diesem Dogma zurückkehren follow the
science ja was ja nicht nur hier als
Hammer benutzt wird als Vorschlag haben
wir um und missliebige oder abweichende
Meinung tot zu schlagen es gibt kein
keine wissenschaftliche
wahrheitsdogmatik ja und Wissenschaft
lernt genauso wie wir alle außerhalb der
Wissenschaft auch lernen
wenn wir wenn wir die Politiker dazu
auffordern jetzt treten vor und sagt am
Beispiel von Corona follow the science
deckt vielleicht 95% ab aber die
entscheidenden 5 % nicht also da muss
man ihn glaube ich ganz genau auf die
Finger gucken vor allem weiß natürlich
auch eine wahnsinnige Geldverschwendung
war die ganzen Tests die ganzen Masken
das hat wahnsinnig viel gekostet jetzt
liegt dort gekühlt Millionen von
Impfdosen auch das kostet Energie jetzt
in einer Energiekrise und währenddessen
auch ein ganz großes Thema bei uns sogar
vergessen jung und sie sagte jeder
zweite Patient bekommt nicht mehr die
Medikamente die er braucht schon einmal
in diesen Beitrag kurz rein
mittlerweile ist es so jeder zweite
Patient der zu mir in die Apotheke kommt
hat irgendein Medikament auf dem Rezept
was nicht lieferbar ist schwer lieferbar
oder sogar gar nicht lieferbar sei es
nun Paracetamol Ibuprofen Säfte für die
Kleinsten in unserem Lande eine Mutter
lieben mit im Notdienst steht und ich
kann hier keine Paracetamolzäpfchen
geben und das Kind hat wo es Fieber ist
einfach dramatisch und ich frage mich
wirklich wo wir mit diesem Land noch hin
wollen wenn wir solche Banalitäten die
einfach vor 15 Jahren selbstverständlich
waren mittlerweile nicht mehr liefern
können das also Frau jung die uns auch
gestern geschildert hat wie Menschen in
die Apotheke kommen mit Tränen in den
augenhilfe brauchen und sie sie abweisen
musste werden dafür ganz viele
Zuschriften bekommen von Menschen die
sagten es geht uns ganz genauso und zwar
quer durch Deutschland schauen wir
einmal rein dass wir für Zuschriften
bekommen haben über Zwitter über
Facebook haben die an E-Mails haben wir
bekommen hier z.B hat es geschrieben
versuch mal in der Apotheke
sobrazol zu bekommen das ist ein
Magenmittel Hersteller ist ihm egal man
bekommt es einfach nicht einfachste
Mitte Magenmittel Fiebermittel für
Kinder das also die Situation Frau
Hermann aber es sagt das über
Deutschland aus das ist ein Fehler
gewesen ist wesentliche Sachen des
Alltags in auszulagern der Produktion
ich habe vor 10 Jahren ungefähr Mattia
praedesian Zentralindien bereist und hat
dort eben auch Fabriken besucht in denen
z.B Medikamente für Europa hergestellt
werden auch die chemische Industrie die
Vorprodukte Balance Test zum Beispiel da
sieht man in welchen Bereichen Europa
hat überall schon in Indien z.B auch in
anderen Ländern produzieren lassen damit
konnte man hier die Preise künstlich
niedrig halten denn hier wäre es jetzt
zu teuer gewesen dass du zu produzieren
das Problem ist
natürlich immer teurer weil mehr
Nachfrage da ist 4 Milliarden Menschen
in Asien und rum sind jetzt auch alle
auf dem Markt und bei denen wächst die
Kaufkraft deutlich besser als bei uns im
Verhältnis gesehen und das bedeutet auch
dass die sich jetzt Medikamente leisten
können die sich vorher nicht leisten
konnten ich habe ihn irgendwie noch
gesehen wieder Apotheker
aus der Folie drückt und sagt du
brauchst nur drei nimm diese drei ich
behalte die sieben und gebe sie anderen
also das ist eine andere Nummer und wir
werden das in ganz vielen Bereichen noch
feststellen wir haben auch eben
wesentliche Bereiche ausgelagert wo man
im Alltag eben merkt dass man das
braucht wir haben auch bei Lebensmitteln
viel importiert und nicht so viel selber
hergestellt oder produziert manches
können wir ja auch nicht produzieren die
erst Banane wird es nicht geben also
müssen wir alles wir verlieren aber
jetzt noch mehr Produkt